US Customs and Border Protection is
revealing an alarming new milestone this
morning in the fight against opioids
fentanyl and other super potent
synthetic opioids have been pouring into
the United States through international
mail and private carriers seizures of
these illegal shipments are passed
thirty-seven kilos are more than 81
pounds in the fiscal year ending this
week that is a new record Tony to copal
reports from the area in New York's JFK
Airport where most of those packages are
found Tony good morning good morning
this is the busiest international mail
room in America processing more than a
million inbound packages every day
and at a time when your mailman may be
an unwitting drug dealer it's also the
front lines in the opioid crisis spike
here is one of the newest tools in the
hunt for illegal opioids riding this
conveyer belt as an officer fills it
with suspicious packages in this case
all from China so how important are the
dogs to the overall mission incredibly
important because the work that a k-9
can do in an hour is what it would take
an officer eight hours to complete we
don't really know who's sending it port
director Frank Russo runs field
operations at John F Kennedy Airport
where seizures of fentanyl nearly
tripled to more than 80 packages in the
past fiscal year are we talking tens of
millions of dollars hundreds of millions
of dollars at the street level what
we're seizing here is hundreds of
millions of dollars anything flagged by
the dogs or pulled by agents is searched
by hand on this table as we witnessed
after the x-ray machine revealed an
unknown object fentanyl is so toxic that
officers wear gloves and masks to avoid
accidental contact this time it wasn't
fentanyl but GBL commonly used as a
date-rape drug just a little bit of this
mixed in a drink can disable an
individual this is our detention just
one room away however fentanyl
fentanyl fentanyl again correct look at
the bottom here China Hong Kong Hong
Kong is that right cool
that is absolutely typical most of our
seizure and actually all of our seizures
have come from China and Hong Kong this
year and you've also got where it's
going to Pennsylvania in North Carolina
Connecticut are there particular areas
of the country where a lot of this is
headed it's it's that's the the
interesting part Tony is that it's
everywhere it's going absolutely
everywhere moments after we entered the
room a discovery one table away a fresh
seizure happened 35 grams of fentanyl we
can't show it on camera because unlike
these packages those packages may still
go out and be part of an active
investigation how deadly of a dose is
that Tony it's incredibly deadly so 35
grams would be enough to knock over
everyone in this room yeah what
absolutely
the port director here believes they've
dramatically reduce the amount of
fentanyl that makes its way into America
but the only way to reach a perfect
record they say is better International
Cooperation so they have information
about these packages long before they
get here all right Tony thanks spikes
moving so quickly on the belt it doesn't
even seem like he can get a sniff yeah
well he's well trained that's for sure
like it's very good on the job
thank you again Tony I had treachery
sick for gonna say Charlie this bike I
love the way it's bike Oh